[Music]
as a dog returns to its vomit so a fool
repeats his scenes in a previously on
segment
or something it's basically in the bible
and that thing's full of sins
you wouldn't have heard of me dance off
bro he's a friend from work
these opening self blogos accompanied by
the marvel quote all-stars or like that
guy from work that can't quit talking
about his weekend to buy
we get it shane you did some cool stuff
now can you please get back to work
those crew neck tees aren't going to
fold themselves
throwing in the moon landing in greta
thunder at the end of 30 full seconds of
marvel miasma to make your opening feel
more important than it actually is
i know disney feels like they own
everything but it seems a little ballsy
to put a post-apocalyptic hogwarts in
your tv show without even getting
permission from warner brothers
man i hope we get to find out all the
cool things about this castle like what
kind of stone it's made of with those
awesome cracks or maybe it was a monster
that did them my money's on the kraken
but
i'm sure the show will let us know soon
enough there's no way this episode will
just be scenes of people having
conversations the entire time
good thing that would never happen
already okay
yeah just need a moment no you take your
moments in episodes three
or four at the latest by the time you're
at the final episode you don't take
moments you do the thing that the show's
been building up to for the past five
episodes damn it loki i'm tired of
taking moments i'm really [ __ ] sick
and tired of it
phew sorry about that i'm clearly the
one wearing the horns today
i was pruned before you even existed
were you though i thought pruning was
when they officially zapped you with a
rainbow baton of existential nothingness
which literally just happened
before that weren't you just kidnapped
also how do you know who existed first
just because you got yoinked into the
tva first doesn't mean they didn't pull
you from a time that postdated this loki
your words matter sylvie i have been
waiting for this moment my entire life
i just need a second to get my head
straight okay
castle door is addicted to people
needing a second
once at a wedding reception i requested
a van halen song but the tj almost put a
crisscross track on instead
anyhow i hate jump scares he's impressed
who's impressed hey who remains either
playing the pronoun game when it's not
needed or
self nicknaming via the pronoun game i'm
actually so annoyed right now i'm not
going to pick i'm just going to give two
sins and sort it out later
you can kill thanos hiddleston's
reaction here is great but would he
really have that much emotion just from
seeing a highlight reel earlier of what
thanos did in reality he was never even
really part of
you want the infinity gauntlet yours i
get that if you're gonna keep an
antagonist around in this kind of
capacity humanizing him is just part of
the process
look what star trek eventually did to
the borg that doesn't mean i have to
like it
loki would take this deal or at least
the interesting version of loki would
take this deal the not deal taking loki
is a loki of lies
i mean all loki's are bookies of lies
but this one is a loki of different lies
two loki's
in the same place someone hasn't studied
their time cop
shooting video in portrait mode checking
for dust without a white glove on
most of dust is human skin loki and now
you're basically wearing someone else's
skin on your skin you creep oh
this is wild what that the villain eats
an apple thing is so mainstream now that
marvel's just whipping it out front and
center instead of doing it on the sly
and hiding their shame
agree come on marvel don't you realize
how naked your cliche is here if only
there were a metaphor for the moment you
wake up become aware of your sin and
feel ashamed
well either way come on let's talk from
my office
spending any amount of time in a marvel
tv show talking in an office
two sugars thinking the two sugars can
fix the nastiness that is tea
or coffee or whatever drink you've
convinced yourself is actually good even
though it's so bitter it's primarily
responsible for keeping the sweetener
industry in business
oh well you know one man's void is
another man's piece of cake
title of my sex tape why is the coat
drive poster in rinslayer's office
wouldn't that be better served out in
the hallway or
even on the outside school walls so more
people were aware of it happening there
will be kids without coats this winter
because school doesn't know how to
advertise correctly
calling your school the ohio state
university
you're not special but guys no matter
how many articles you insert before your
title
everything that's uh that's going to
happen
there's only one way this can go does it
involve disney making anus loads of
money
i bet it involves disney making anus
loads of money no you can't get to the
end until you've been
changed by the journey this stuff it
needs to happen
to get us all in the in the right
mindset to finish
the quest jonathan majors is not my dm
in this scene
free will free will i give all the sins
back right now if the fresh prince
suddenly leapt over rinslayer from
behind and she trailed her fingers on
his skin as he passed above her and then
swam to freedom
eons of friendship and you threw it all
away on a couple of loki's
as interesting a character she's become
i'm kind of starting to wish this show
was called rinslayer instead of loki
but it is not and just who are you i've
been dubbed many
names by many people a ruler a conqueror
we'll get back to your regularly
scheduled sinning here in a bit but damn
i gotta take some sins
off the fact that marvel reveals a major
villain sure to have a huge impact on
the mcu in one of their tv shows the
sign the game's completely changed take
some real shonen ads to put this much
faith in your plan and i've gotta give
some respect
also jonathan majors is absolutely
pulverizing this role
he's so brilliant compelling and
charismatic that i forgot my job here is
to sin things not
fan slobber all over him i'm sorry won't
let it happen again
eons ago before the tva
exposition via some sort of mercury
theater is still exposition
i bet you didn't even get permission
from orson welles he discovered that
there were
universes stacked on top of the zone
those look more like solar systems than
universes but whatever king the
expositioner you do you
i love your shoes i love your hair oh
man nice nose thanks man
[Laughter]
oh it happened again didn't it however
not every version of me
was so so pure of heart and the director
said remember that obvious apple
metaphor from earlier let's pat it home
even more and have him take another bite
right in the middle of talking about the
[ __ ] versions of himself because
subtlety am i right
god the way the music is in harmony with
his vocal performance and the general
amazingness of this natalie holt
soundtrack is blowing my mind
nope not again um pretentiously singing
it almond when we all know it's amen
saved it once i isolated our timeline
all i have to do is manage the flow of
time
and prevent any further branches oh is
that all
tva it works or you're a liar
there are so many more possibilities
than that let's get some gray in there
marvel not every scenario is black or
white
marvel or dc laverne or shirley also
side note it's totally shirley
oh villains here one's been a bit
neutered but sure
oh now how you use magic i haven't been
this annoyed with mythical creatures
relying on modern weaponry since
underworld hot leather pants
glad to see the mtu isn't faltering on
their stabby stabby pew pew finale
resolutions
there's something to be said about being
consistently predictable with the final
battles
stop stop she already did somehow in the
midst of a ferocious kill swing despite
you not saying this till
after you appeared in the direct line of
that kill shot that somehow did not kill
you
is i don't want to hurt you i don't want
to close my eyes
i don't wanna fall asleep cause i miss
you baby
and i don't wanna miss a thing
sorry i black out and sing aerosmith
when i get bored by what's going on in
front of me there's a reason people have
stopped inviting me to weddings
and funerals it's masturbation but i'm
not you
wait you mean not you you or like not
you at all
like not a loki or not this loki if you
think making me wait a year to find out
the answer to this isn't gonna get you a
sin
you're right because you're getting five
i'm turning back now
hey remember these important characters
that were developed so nicely through
the last five episodes and then given
[ __ ]
to do in the finale yeah me either i
should probably start a sidekick's
anonymous support group with taurus from
falcon and sharon and todd davis from
wand division with an emphasis on the
anonymous
for all time always roll king mercials
who are you what's your name nice twist
you got there be a shame if someone came
along and questioned the logic of it but
why would sylvia programmed him to go to
an alternate timeline or universe why
would that timeline or universe be in
the exact same time and with the same
people as he left it and why would those
people not know who he is when the
timelines didn't diverge till
after he left how would there even be a
tva in a different timeline or universe
i'm sure you'll explain it to me in the
comments and
marvel will pretend to answer some of
these questions but i'm guessing it
comes down mostly to
it's complicated okay and that ain't
enough
breaking the fourth dimensional wall
go back to then when now now no i can't
why we missed it when just now and what
have we always wanted the whole place
organized by style cross-referenced by
size and reverse indexed by fabric
she'll be able to find anything in three
seconds flat
it was some of my best work
pay no attention to that man behind the
curtain
and just who are you i am king
do not be frightened we mean you no harm
you you speak english i am actually
speaking right
by an astonishing coincidence both of
our languages are exactly the same
you came to kill the devil right
we beat the devil with our rock
i've lived a million lifetimes a million
dollars isn't cool you know what's cool
a billion dollars
[Music]
hold it hold it what is this
is this a kissing book